una mañana un mediodía bien movido aquí
en la sede de la con 26 como ustedes
pueden ver a mis espaldas miles de
personas tratan de encontrar un espacio
donde será el mejor lugar para
presenciar lo que se espera puede ser
una cumbre histórica por los buenos
resultados o porque definitivamente los
líderes no logran ponerse de acuerdo en
ese punto de inflexión para salvar el
planeta hemos visto circular entrar a
este recinto el presidente francés
emmanuel macrón a la presidenta de la
unión europea de la comisión europea
úrsula von der layen entre otros líderes
mundiales que se reúnen desde hoy aquí
en glasgow la estrategia que el reino
unido quiere presentar al mundo se basa
en cuatro puntos el primero de ellos es
acabar con el uso del carbón para
producir energía los países del g7 se
han comprometido en ello pero no fue así
por los países del g20 también en lograr
esa transformación y acabar con el uso
la venta de nuevos carros que usen
combustibles fósiles como gasolina y
diésel y se transformen entonces los
eléctricos también recursos millonarios
para ayudar especialmente a los países
necesitados a los países en vías de
desarrollo que necesitan los recursos de
los países ricos para poder lograrlo el
reino unido anunciará además mil
millones de dólares para este fondo y
además bien importante raúl la siembra
de árboles en todo el mundo pero como
les digo una cumbre que arranca con un
optimismo más bien bajo por todo lo
sucedido en roma con los líderes del g20
vamos a ver entonces qué pasa en esta en
esta cumbre louis y también como usted
lo dijo hablemos ahora el presidente
manera cono porque esta cumbre tiene
lugar en medio de las tensiones entre
macro y johnson también
si definitivamente aunque por supuesto
no es un tema puesto oficialmente sobre
la mesa porque quiere darse el
protagonismo a una necesidad para cada
uno de nosotros si es que va a ser el
mundo los líderes internacionales para
salvar el mundo pero por supuesto está
este asunto esta fricción entre el reino
unido y francia- por los derechos
pesqueros hoy la ministra de exteriores
británica liz trust ha puesto sobre la
mesa asuntos bien complejos ha dado un
dead line un tiempo límite de 48 horas
para que francia ayude a resolver esta
disputa por los derechos pesqueros antes
de que avance y podría incluso tomar
acciones legales y francia también ha
dicho que mañana el 2 de noviembre es el
plazo máximo que dará para que el reino
unido- resuelva esta situación el
gobierno británico ha dicho que ha
cedido en un 98 por ciento de las
pretensiones de las solicitudes de
licencias de pescadores franceses pero
eso no es justamente lo que piensan en
el otro lado del canal de la mancha es
que los derechos pesqueros después del
son absolutamente fundamentales para los
dos lados del canal de la mancha
recordemos fue uno de los iconos de la
campaña del reino unido para salir de la
unión europea y entonces recuperar esa
autonomía sobre las aguas británicas